هناك نبا اذا عن ان الخارجيه الروسيه
استدعت دبلوماسيين امريكيين كبار وذلك
احتجاجا على تصريحات امريكيه بشان الهجمات
داخل روسيا حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
موسكو مراسل الجزيره امين درغامي امين ما
هي هذه التصريحات المقصوده وماذا في
تفاصيل هذا النبا
اما ال سي بيان وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
اكد على ان الخارجيه استدعت
كبار الدبلوماسيين في السفاره الامريكيه
للاحتجاج على تصريحات الجانب الامريكي
وتحديدا تصريحات مستشاره الامن القومي
الامريكي جون سوليفان بتاييده للهجمات
الاوكرانيه على الاراضي الروسيه بما فيها
شبه جزيره القرم وبيل الخارجيه اكدت على
ان الجانب الروسي قدم احتجاجا شديدا
اللهجه للجانب الامريكي
واتهم الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بمواصله
ما تسميه روسيا بالنهج العدائي لوشنطن
تجاه روسيا عبر مد الجانب الاوكراني
باسلحه استخدمتها القوات الاوكرانيه في
التورغل والتسلل الى داخل الاراضي الروسيه
في اشاره واضحه الى تلك العربات القتاليه
الامريكيه التي استخدمتها المجموعه التي
كانت قد دخلت
قبل ثلاثه ايام هذا البيان ايضا اكد على
ان هذا النهج الذي وصفه بالعداء للجانب
الامريكي تجاه روسيا
اغرق او او وصل العلاقات بين البلدين الى
مرحله خطيره لا يمكن التنبؤ
بتبيعاتها المستقبليه وشدد على ان الجانب
الروسي اوصل الى نظيره الامريكي بان مثل
هذه التصرفات الامريكيه ستقابل في
المستقبل برد حازم من قبل الجانب روسي في
الحقيقه هذا البيان ياتي تعقيبا على
تصريحات جونسون وكانت الخارجيه في وقت
سابق على لسان المتحدث باسمها ماريا زخربه
قد اعتبرت ان عدم ان تصريحات الامريكيه
بانها ستزود الجانب الاوكراني باسلحه
ولكنها ترفض ان تستهدف بها اراضي روسيا
بانها شكل من اشكال النفاق كما قالت حينها
زخرفه شكرا جزيلا لك مراسلنا امين درغامي
من موسكو